all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath live I am your host
comedian Joel Byers
this is comedians on skype talking
comedy if you're watching this on
YouTube all the questions are being
asked within our Facebook group so if
you'd like to join in on Future q and
A's click the link in the description
join our Facebook group and start
connecting with comedians like today's
guest who was actually on our podcast
way back in episode 68 this was back in
2016 is now 2020 and she has done so
many amazing things since then and we're
so excited to have her please welcome
back to hot breath the one and only Emma
Willman ladies and gentlemen give it up
for Emma Willman I am doing great it's
so great to connect with you I know like
I was thinking about it when we booked
this I was like remember it was in it
was in the basement of the Laughing
Skull yeah and it was Jo I you were just
like in town for like I don't even know
like not long and we just scheduled it
and then to see what you've done it was
a college on a Wednesday and then I was
like air B&B and ice and Prince in
Atlanta so I was like I'll stay and
visit them and then I did some guest
spots at the at the club that weekend
that was in its it was cool you adjust
yeah laughing schools great yeah and you
had just I think you had just been on
Colbert not that long ago and I was in
this mindset at the time I'm not anymore
like I love just being a comedian
continue to grow and evolve but at that
time I was like I gotta get a late-night
set I need that validation and you
actually like you shared the Booker's
info with me I mean you were like yeah
go for it but what's interesting in
researching you to follow up with this
with our follow up interview here is
like
you're in this big mindset of just
focusing on what you can control and not
anything else and do you think that
think a lot about but what do you it
seems like you have it seems like you've
figured out something since the last
time we talked in the past four years
it seemed what what did you figure out
Emma I'm curious appreciate that very
much
so you've you're now on your third
podcast your content is very well it's
consistent it's of a very high quality
it seems like it's a very intentional
kind of marketing strategy you do now
all the way from like your business to
even like personal side it seems like
you took a big shift in your overall
personal health as well like what was it
taken care of yourself first that then
helped for your career to take off not
help anything
but I remember I would kind of like you
know if you're prescribed at your
prescribed it like a certain way one a
day not like none for a week I'm about
to do college I'll take a bunch so it
wasn't a healthy or sustainable way to
beat so I stopped doing that probably
pretty soon after I did Colbert that
first time and being healthier
definitely helps everything I know
there's like that mindset of like I mean
sometimes I'll feel like if I'm in a
place will have a better show because I
just don't care but I don't know if that
is necessarily true or just like a
narrative I'll tell myself to not try to
make to be like wallow and feeling angry
or whatever what do they do feel like
I'm in a much better place than I was
then and with with the content yeah that
was kind of uh it was seeing like other
I mean like in New York
Andrew Schultz has been hitting it with
the content for a while and so when you
see someone being like oh I didn't know
I said I could put that type of stuff
out there then that started I mean at
the podcast so now I do - I do the tube
podcast
Emma's bunker and inside the closet not
secret keepers but and then I'll do a
morning radio thing once a week but it
was just seeing kind of like being
inspired by how what other people are
like sharing and then just wanting to
share I guess so first yeah I wanna I
want to dive deeper into both of those
topics but first just on the the
personal health just because I feel like
this is something I talk about mark
Normand with as well was just like
taking care of your own health he said
when he started taking care of his
personal health more not from the
drinking clearly but he's starting
exercising and things like that that he
started to find more success in his
career and I have found little spurts of
that when I get good momentum on my
health that more positive things start
to happen like have you seen that and
what did you specifically change in your
life whether diet or exercise that is
attributed to that so I would say it
started with not drinking and then I was
starting not good at saying like I would
have a hard time I need to plan shows in
a way that is sustainable because when
you start getting some good I remember
one time saying when I first was getting
colleges the Booker was like hey I had a
show in from a show in Arkansas music I
had a cancelation at a college in
Vermont but you'd have to get from
Arkansas to Vermont and there's not a
direct flight where you're going so do
you want me to book you in this because
I had this drop out you like it was like
a last minute thing and I remember
saying yeah you book it I'll figure out
even it's just if it's just my car
it's all good not say it's not doing
things where I have to say refer to
myself as a carcass definitely helped me
like if I have to say yeah yeah just get
my dead body
I'll just get my dead my body will be
dead but I'll get it there mm-hmm
if I hear myself have to say something
like that I'll go you know what I'm not
gonna I can't do that I'm not gonna be
able to make it I don't need to and it's
not gonna be productive or good for them
they could have a better show from
someone who's not taking a red-eye and
driving and it was like winter and I
remember like whipping through the snow
like a dysfunctional Santa Claus just a
total mess I think that it also made me
enjoy comedy a little bit more because I
didn't have everything wasn't resting on
the stand-up so if you're like if you're
getting really unhealthy and then you're
you're just like okay I'm doing this in
your brain because I'm new I have to for
comedy then so much rest on each show so
if you had a bad show you're like there
goes the validation for my whole life
and that's not good show bad show you
just want to take something for it for
the next thing mm-hmm
yeah it's I just had that experience
where I did I drove like six hours one
way for not a lot of money oh it was it
was depressing it was gas money and I
booked it like five months in advance
before I was even thinking of myself as
someone who deserved better I drove
there I I showed up 15 minutes late to
the show and I was like it was like it
was like it was a comedy zone gig so I
was it was like a host and headliner
they do like a two-person show a lot of
time so imagine driving six hours
knowing you're going to be late on the
other end of that trip but that was the
moment for me where I'm like I need to
be more strategic and mindful about what
is the return
you know the show I was driving to
Syracuse from New York and I got stuck
in traffic and while I'm driving I'm
knowing there's no way
I'm gonna make like it was just I think
I had two hours to drive four hours I'm
writing because I'm I was like so fast I
got pulled over I was like I get to my
show and the guy was like where's the
show I told him where was he said well
first of all you're criminals meeting
you yeah I'm gonna give you a ticket
second of all you're not gonna make that
show and it took like another half hour
of me even driving before I was like I'm
not gonna make it so that was a learning
that was definitely a learning thing as
well and you you seem do you yeah you
seem to have like pinpointed on strategy
do you are you more strategic in where
your comedy career is headed now are you
more like thoughtful or organized about
it I I know that the best answer for
that I mean yes in that I hope as you
keep doing things like almost by like
osmosis maybe you become more like
strategic and better about stuff I think
that I had really been for maybe like
two or three years and then
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah there's no wrong answer it's okay
ever feel like you're doing it the right
way
especially with comedy too and then
trying to figure out like having the
right people around you is like a tricky
that's I think it's easier to if you
have like a specific thing that you're
working on or working towards today I
think the strategy is like built into
that but I would say I definitely have a
clearer sense of my voice and what I
enjoy doing that's for sure so I guess I
guess by by that I have a clearer idea
of what I like to do and then trying to
say yes to doing that type of thing that
has helped me be more strategic how were
you able to find your voice you know I
would say it would be it was like a it
was part me growing as a person but then
also like trusting finding audiences
that I would like trust like I did this
morning show called now called Taylor
Strecker show and her audience is so
great and I'd always have so much fun
with them and then there would be
certain things I would say that I liked
to talk about but then they would were
the way that they would respond with
Abuk oh this is great I didn't
necessarily know this is what people
would be down to listen to - and then
just trusting myself more and also I got
to tell you what the more TV that I
watched that helped you cause like there
are certain I remember watching an
episode of broad city and I was like
this is so funny
that first season I remember being like
this is so funny and that when they made
this they put this out there you know
having faith that there would be people
that would come forward and receive this
so then that made me be like you got to
put out stuff that you like and then
connect with the people through that and
not just try to do something you think
people will like you wanna do something
actually like stand behind - boom that's
something we can be guilty as as
comedians is just like what's gonna go
viral what is what is the algorithm
break down it's more just creating what
you enjoy
yeah not someone said this to me so I
can't take credit for this line but
those are really good when they were
like you know I'm not even using that
microphone that I have near my other one
in my head
the it's you don't always have to start
at the finish line because I think some
times what we see like when you see
stuff on social media it's usually the
finished product of something so then
you're like well I don't know how to
connect the dots to create that so how
am I even going to start but they didn't
start with that they started way back
with learning how to do an editing
program or getting a video camera
whatever so thinking that you have to
start with that viral video that you see
you don't remember there's a lot of
other videos before that that maybe you
haven't seen but that was part of their
process too so you don't have to start
at the you don't have to start at the
best thing ever because that's
impossible
and you do have to start you do have to
start yeah you have to put in there work
yeah yeah and you can you know you're
great you had talked about having like a
strategy but also like a specific vision
behind what you want to accomplish so is
that when you were saying two or three
years ago is when you really had it
dialed in was what we're like the things
that you were envisioning that you were
then able to work towards specifically
you know I would say the thing where I
that I really like felt like I
manifested the most and not that it
necessarily worked out but it was
something I really manifested I remember
like years ago wanting to work with this
manager very tight oh yeah picturing him
always picturing him picturing those
years and years ago
picturing because I do believe in self
actualization um I remember picturing
him picturing him picturing him and then
I wrote somewhere I was I Chelsea
Handler had come out with the book are
you there God has to meet Chelsea and I
had a picture of me looking up and I
said are you there Barry it's me Emma
this is years ago and he wrote me on
facebook it was like did you mean to tag
me and I was like I started a log and
then I remember when I went to go meet
him taking this escalator up his office
was like all these escalator floors up
and taking the escalator up and it was
so surreal because I was like I pictured
this moment and now I'm living this
moment and I've had that with a few
other like before like a TV thing or
that moment like right before you have
to go on I felt that when I was in the
drug with crazx I remember
being like I want to do a TV show I want
to do a TV show and then like there's
that moment where you're thinking about
it all the time then you kind of do the
steps and then when it's happening
you're like oh these two things have
merged I've had that would positive I
think that you can manifest positive
things and then I get scared cuz like
sometimes I'll picture like I have this
vision of me in Florida it's like
something like not the coast like in the
middle bar and I'm like eating like like
like they're not warm anymore onion
rings mmm and things never worked out
and then and someone's like what do you
do it I'm like I was trying to make it
in show business I have that visual and
since when that pops in my brain I'm
like I gotta get out of here because I
don't want to like bring that into
existence mm-hmm so it's not like always
easy to just picture like I want to get
more disciplined about being like no
this is a positive thing I want work
towards that and you were for the Barry
Katz visualization you would like a lot
time every day to visualize vividly like
being in the room with him type deal
yeah it was it was it was almost like I
think I've looked and read things like
the secret more which is a book where
that's what she talks about a lot that
you do it to take with a grain of salt
but there's a lot of like visualization
stuff I think I had done that more after
I think I was I was just doing it
naturally like I wanted that so much
that I was just picturing picturing
picturing and then it came to be and
then when I learned more like oh there's
a whole thought process and you know
like ideas of like goal setting behind
that then I tried to do it more like
strategically as you said but it was
sometimes when you know the back end of
how you're supposed to do things it
doesn't necessarily mean you're gonna do
it more you just then have the tools to
like recreate the thing you did
naturally ah so how did that meeting go
it's a great meeting I think we worked
together for about a year and it was
that era yeah I mean that first meet
that was great I had a very good
experience with him I don't think it was
the time for me to be I was like just
starting out there wasn't a lot but it
wasn't a good timing thing but I had
that first meeting was a great meeting I
look back on those like meetings and
memories
like extremely fondly and I've never
been in one of those meetings what
happens is it more like hey Emma I see
you tagged me or like I'm sorry I just
did my first Barry Katz impression
everyone has one eye that was mine I
guess I've been visualizing that was
very like all the way with all windows
and this is not what a meeting could be
run the gamut of like anything but this
meeting was and it was one of the first
ones like this I had done so I was like
right yeah and even you go in his office
and your greet his you know an assistant
and an intern greet you and I remember
going in and Jesus was there no there
was a giant white couch there was like
this giant white couch coffee table big
desk and then and then he was there so
it was and there was like windows out
overlooking Hollywood so is what you
would picture that's not what lots of
meetings are just like you're in like a
conference room mm-hmm you know well
what do you what do you talk about cuz
apparently he wanted to work with you so
is he asking like what is your strategy
what is your plan type deal it was good
he yeah so so in those meetings it's a
lot like so it's a lot like it's like a
first business date so there so that
would be a meeting where that's once
there's something called a general
meeting okay is it so a general meeting
is when usually someone sets you up with
someone at like a production company or
a casting thing or something and you
generally meet them okay
now I've done a million billion general
meetings I kind of think it's a time for
some people in the entertainment
industry and now I have friends that
like work at production companies and
cut and media and they'll be like okay
kind of it's like a paid way to have a
break in our day so and then so it is
would it but this
meeting was more than a general meeting
because we'd already like generally
talked and there was like the oh
interesting working together so it was
more like yeah tell me about yourself
what are your goals and then I think if
someone was someone would now that I've
been doing this longer someone would say
and here's what I've assessed from what
you're doing and here's where I would
help you so actually this if I have some
advice in part I think so much we're
working towards being like the giver in
it and being and wanting someone to want
to work with us we forget to stop and
say so what are you gonna do for me in
this equation here's everything I've
worked for here's everything I want to
do here's what I think I can offer and
then just wanting them to Beck yeah I
want to work with you but stop what's
that person gonna how are they gonna
contribute to that conversation and do
you believe them because then in these
you gotta look at yourself as having
some value too because then then they
then you pay that you know what I'm
saying so like if you if you were hiring
someone you're hiring a babysitter
you're hiring some gonna mow their your
lawn you'd be like you wouldn't think
this is my house isn't my lawn oh well
the grass is so easy to mow it'll be so
fun for you to do could you imagine
doing that and then never stop going to
be like you belong more you gotta see if
they have something they can even do the
things with so make sure you interview
when if you do not on a general meeting
because that's are scary to generally
know each other but if you're in a
meeting where it's like we're gonna work
together in some capacity see what their
plan is for you and then if you can
trust that and people in entertainment
are genuinely very charming as well
which can be tough yeah Alonzo Bodden
actually we just did one with him last
week and he was saying if a manager
takes you out to lunch and doesn't pay
that manager is not for you yeah yeah
also maybe you want someone that's like
watched your content to like someone
could I mean if they're taking you out
to lunch then they're not taking you up
wow you're having much yeah but that I
would agree with that because then it
would have been better for them to be
like come in and meet or like let's get
coffee something that they could you
know what I mean yeah
all right let's get into the I think
questions like there's a friend of mine
she's so talented and he's been fixated
on I don't have a manager which I relate
to - I remember thinking that before I
had ever worked with one I think we get
fixated on these things cuz
entertainment comedy is so vast and
broad it's hard to just like have that
thing to work for it so it's something
to work towards mm-hmm
and I think if you're hitting the table
and it's picking up so I'm actually
curious
no I'm is you're I'm wonder if your mics
picking up because I don't know if that
Mike would pick up the table is the mic
on or plugged in okay I just want to
make sure cuz I was hearing the table
but I didn't know you know as a fellow
podcaster you know there's always gonna
be someone who's like that interview was
amazing but your audio I hate you you
know it's like oh my god exactly yeah
and I actually had an interview ended up
getting ruined because she was playing
with her keys the whole time the entire
interview playing with her keys and I
this was probably like the fifth or
sixth interview I ever did so I didn't
even know what was going on and then it
was you couldn't even listen to it
it was Audia was ruined and I haven't
been able to get her back so it's fine
one time I this is really bad I was a
cut I think I cut like to knit to
toenails while I was recording I've
never lived it down because like and it
was inside the closet it was like people
were like was doing that Matteo it was
like community I do with he was like it
wasn't me and the intern was like it
wasn't me and then I was like I can't
believe because I thought I had like you
did my whatever I did I didn't do it
right and it was so I can't imagine keys
the whole time yeah yeah this was this
was just cling-clang cling-clang
just the whole time and it was bad
because she's she's like the manager of
the punchline here Atlanta so she's been
in the business like since the 80s she
has stories with every comic you can
imagine like she was sharing Eddie
Murphy stories and like and then none of
it was usable and I had to I had to
really convince her to do it the first
time and since then she she hasn't I'm
still on we're still gonna get her but
it's just like one of those well still
what maybe if you preface it we're like
look there's some cleaning things are
gonna be clinking around there's a ton
of clinking I regret the clinking but I
promise you it's a good interview only
listen if you can handle the clinking so
don't know surprises
what's the hell's is clicking yeah
here's the deal here are the stories
it's not a bad idea
okay okay we'll put it on the patreon
that's all right let's get into these
questions because we had people excited
when I was sharing it saying how much
they just loved you so all right all
right let's get into let's get into this
first one here and we're actually gonna
start with Marx because we've been on
the subject of like shifts within your
career so we'll start with Marx here so
this is Mark white he asks Emma can you
think of your greatest breakthrough
milestone or vent and what led up to it
I would say the greatest breakthrough
I'm gonna say I'm gonna tell you two of
them okay with the tracing back with the
real breakthrough honestly was when I
got into the college market and I'm not
in that market anymore I don't really do
any call I don't do schools anymore but
and that was so how that came about was
I did this thing called access TV and
now when I'm gonna say breakthrough I'm
gonna turn I'm gonna use that in regards
to becoming like a professional
entertainer so I had done this thing
called access TV it was like a cable
access show that was called it was live
at Gotham gothic comedy club in New York
and I did that and I remember and it was
a really good tape and I asked somebody
this guy used to intern for when I was
in college I interned for a guy who ran
shows he was like a event producer and I
said do you know anybody in the college
market that I could send this to and he
said he was like yeah I know this one
guy so I sent the tape to this guy he
gets back to me right away and he's like
yeah I want in let's work together you
look like Ellen let's do this so I was
like that was easy so then I sent the
tape to a bunch of other college agents
being like oh I already got this the
first guy the second person was like
okay you know you swore Pass and then
the person was like okay how much time
do you have you have an hour I was like
10 minutes and they were like call me in
four years
mmm and then the next Bert and then the
next person didn't I don't know II
didn't get back to me so I circle back
to the first guy he never asked how much
time I had he was just like let's do
this so I started working with him and
he submitted me to the nakos and when I
got in that first year I got into these
nakos which is where you showcase our
colleges and once I got into those then
I was able to get a manager and an agent
because I was I had something to offer
monetarily where I was like hey I'm
doing these things where I'm making
money do you want to be a part of what
I'm doing for that and then it cut so
that really was a big break for me
because all of a sudden I was doing
things on like a professional level and
then I would say the next break was
doing Colbert but that college break it
was like that break happened and then
things moved like pretty quick from
there in terms of getting the schools
getting the other traction with anything
else I've done that's been kind of like
a break where it's like you break
through something and then you're like
up another thing mm-hmm
you know in some regards things don't
haven't happened fast after that in my
lake where it's like and I think that
that's like dangerous thinking where
it's like being like like I remember
after I did just for laughs I remember
being like okay and then nothing so I
felt like I had done something wrong I
remember I remember actually that's when
I was with Barry Katz and I remember
sitting with him
is really surreal because if you've seen
the documentary comedian you know where
he's with orny Adams at just relapsed
near this fireplace and I sat with him
there what
and also Joel guess what I saw or neon
atoms there - Wow I'm sitting with Barry
Katz and I C or D atoms and guess what
he was doing he was taking a selfie of
himself here at the bar which is if
you've seen the documentary that's the
most like what you would expect he's
literally at the bar trying to get the
perfect selfie oh my god I was just like
yeah and life is weird but I remember
asking I was like is it all over for me
because I I just felt okay about my
showcase and he was like what are you
cats was like what do you what are you
talking about and I was like is it over
for me I just did okay he was like no
and then I was expecting I don't know
anytime you start expecting then that
really is like a danger zone because
anything you don't get whatever
expecting no it's hard to keep moving
forward if you never expect anything
because then you're like what's the
point but the less you can expect that
isn't something that you have a direct
hand in the better I say and that comes
back I would say that's oh that was a
bit that was the first like break I you
know and that's something that you can
you can create that break yeah is that
way what did you I guess it was like oh
nevermind he didn't say what you
attribute to it he said what led up to
it so you did say that I'll say this I
mean I think it helped that I picked off
the like gay box with the colleges so I
can't say oh just a platica and this I
mean I had a really good tape and even
with doing those showcases I remember
whatever my jokes were I was running
them by the college agent he was like
why don't you come out say you're gay
you're dyslexic
it's like Suffolk and I was like oh I
was due I was open it was something
about you know me and my sister somebody
was like yeah yeah your sisters what I'm
like you know 19 months younger than me
she's like he's like no she straightened
your oh wow but he was I mean it's
terms of booking shows that that didn't
make sense at the time what are some of
the wildest things you've heard in like
a meeting or from someone important who
is like could you gang it up a little
bit or anything like that no one's ever
said that because I think when I like
got into when I started like getting
into those situations that was almost
like old news a little bit okay I one of
the funniest things that happen in a
meeting was it was this production
company I'd met with a couple times and
I was meeting with this one guy and he's
like I'm gonna have you meet my boss so
he brings his boss in for the meeting
and the guy who had been meeting with
before had listened to this podcast I
did and the title of the podcast was
like how do you have sex so he were in
the meeting with his boss and the guy
looks at me he goes he was like yeah
I've been keeping up with you and any
posny went so how do you have sex he's
referencing the podcast his boss looked
he he had no context for what the guy
was talking about so his boss was like
hey I don't know what and like started
like looking at the guy like are you
[ __ ] crazy and then the that guy was
really confused and then I was like no
no he's he's referring to a podcast I
did he's not literally asking me how I
have sex but I think that almost
witnessed this his boss have a heart
attack because he's just like seeing a
lawsuit before his eyes in real time
like he was he like leaned back in his
chair big big big boy bad I thought he
was gonna follow lunges toward me so
that was one of my like favorite
favorite memories of a meeting just
watching that catastrophe unfold but for
the most ridiculous thing said I can't
that I did that was like the most
ridiculous situation the most known but
I've heard a lot of I know I've gone on
auditions where I can tell they want I
had an audition not too long ago and I
was trying I was for like a really like
butch roles for league of their own and
I when I went in I was tryna be in
character and I kind of knew the casting
director so she was like what are you
doing
and she was like oh alright but that's
not a good sign if someone casting
something is like what are you doing and
then you have to be like I'm tryna I'm
kind of sorry right yeah
that's comforting though to know yeah
that there aren't yeah you don't have
any like negative stories of things like
that happening so that's cool yeah that
I mean I think people try to like
protect them I think that that would
someone would have to be like pretty far
gone - oh actually no I was doing it I
was doing a Skype with this production
company and it was me and two other
girls and the guy this this was like
right with me to stuff was starting
mm-hmm we start the call and the guys
like look man - put on some pants put on
some pants and we're all like and then
later in the call one of the girls was
very one of the girls was straight me
and then the other girls gay but she's
very feminine you couldn't tell that she
was gay and he was like so do you have a
boyfriend and he said you have a
girlfriend and then he pointed to her
and he goes if you have a boyfriend she
was like I have a girlfriend and she and
then there was a [ __ ] word silence and
she went she was like I'm gay and he
went and we were all like and we're and
then we're like is that okay and he was
like I mean to me I don't see it as
being anything wrong but I don't know
about basically telling her to be like
in the closet and me and the other girl
were very surprised by that but I want
to know we were already working with
that production company we were like in
a deal where they were gonna produce
something we were doing so that probably
made him more comfortable I bet if it
was like a meeting where we hadn't all
signed on this is a couple years ago
like three or four three years ago if we
had were like interviewing each other I
highly doubt he would have been I could
when he was like I got to put on pants I
was like in the time where everyone's
trying so hard to be so PC that it's
gotten totally ridiculous yeah then you
Skype with someone who like so did you
still work yeah and then he he did get
someone like me gun trouble and then we
kept working together oh wow okay well I
am I am wearing pants I just want the
record to show
that's so bizarre yeah that that's
bizarre
okay so let's let's cleanse our palates
with some comedy process here Christiane
Williams asks what what is your process
when you go back and review your
recorded sets thank you for asking that
Christiane so my process now I will when
I'm the most like structured with it
I'll try to go back and I'll I'll be
playing it and then I'll try to
transcribe and I will transcribing has
definitely been the most productive
thing I'm not as disciplined about it as
I was like to be but I'll transcribe it
and then I'll look for things that are
like redundant and through that editing
process then I'll usually like take a
moment take a couple days and then I'll
start like just like free talking almost
to myself to see if there's something
else I can come up with from that more
structured thing because when I'm
writing on I'll be like all over the
place but then only in the editing one
bag okay
I said I gave this example which I
already gave so I can just only need one
of them so I'll try to mines definitely
a combination of writing on stage and
then writing from just like listening to
sets but I I'll have a hard time with
writing on stage and then remembering
how I said that so that's where I'll try
to like listen back to stuff and when
you transcribe is it always what was the
funniest or is it something that struck
you as like oh there's something
interesting there that could turn into
something funny I'll usually try to do
it where it's something interesting they
could turn into something funny and then
if it if it hasn't turned into something
funny be like okay what's what's wrong
with this thought or like how can I
build on this thought but transcribing
normally talk faster than you can write
so but that's actually helps me with the
transcribing because play transcribe a
little bit stop go back transcribe more
so that helps cuz you're just like
listening to yourself a bunch and that's
definitely productive I find even though
that sucks
it sucks I mean it's I've spent a long
time looking around for other ways to
not have to do that but for me that's
what I found and and also part of the
price if I get really stuck on something
I'll what me
being around other comics and watching
other people do comedy will help me
because it it gets me inspired in that
I'll be like oh this is what it is that
gets me inspired cuz I'll I'll have fun
watching other people if I like them and
then if then watching them will make me
be like oh yeah comedy is fun people are
enjoying this this is fun go back try to
tap into that instead of the mental
cramp of being like and I think I've
noticed in being a fan of yours and
seeing the evolution of your comedy is
it does seem like you're having more fun
on stage does that is that intentionally
translating like you're like I found
when I had more fun with the audience
they would have more fun with me was
that something you had to develop and be
aware of because there's much more like
open energy yeah I think the longer you
do it the more because I remember seeing
I remember watching this show and it was
like everyone was bombing and then this
like guy had been doing it forever went
up and he changed the energy in the room
and I think that's a mark of someone
who's been doing it longer we're like
and that comes in with acting I have a
friend who is a comedian and an actress
and I was like well no matter what
you're feeling you bring the same energy
onstage and she was like yeah cuz that
energy goes with my material so she was
like I need to bring that because that
applies to what I'm talking about in the
material so that made me start to think
about okay I'll try to like create the
fun before the fun is happening and then
it kind of can go from there but that
can also be kind of emotionally
exhausting and it's hard to do with
you're in Las Vegas why is that man I
don't know like Las Vegas is tough so
that's where I like buckle down the most
and and then it's like pushed me like a
dead porpoise uppa do you have it do you
have any rituals or a process to getting
in that energy zone even when you're not
feeling like it mm-hmm so what I'll do
is I'll pace around and then this is
something I'll say if it's something
where I'll feel like nerves or I start
thinking about other stuff this is
something that brings me back to the
moment I'll say it's just you and the
people
you and the people it's just you and the
people and that to me creates the energy
of between just me and them and not
thinking about all these other things in
my life or other people who might be
thinking of something or there's someone
there that I might get nervous about
seeing me get them out of my head cuz
it's just me and the people me and the
people and business people will come
around to what's happening with you and
the people the industry my I feel might
pick someone that they like but then if
the people don't eventually come around
those aren't your real friends
eventually they're gonna follow the
people buying the tickets so they'll
come around to whatever is happening you
know if you're if you're you and the
people you and the people I mean I
definitely seen like industry bet on
some people were it's like the person
and the people is not happening maybe
haven't heard them in the industry and
then I don't know how that plays out
long-term and that ties back to when you
were talking about in the college market
it's like you got a manager because you
had something to offer monetarily it's
like was like totally awesome and he
might say well I also like you cause
like other I thought you were funnier oh
yeah but in my brain there was like a
clear thing to go back to I think that's
what got the email open I literally the
subject buying an email was like I'm
doing a bunch of colleges you want to
talk like something like that to pique
the interest yeah I mean no that's it's
a business relationship and like I under
interviewed the head of comedy
innovative artists and her her thing was
yeah like if you want a manager you need
first something to manage so that's all
a he's like yeah you've got to bring
something the table totally alright the
next one
bring some table this cuz it's so tough
cuz like someone could have so many
things they're bringing to the table
that then they don't get a manager but
it's like you still have stuff to bring
to the table they that particular person
just didn't see it so back to comedy
writing here this is from Chase who was
super jazzed that to see you were on
here I think he just he just rewatched
her net
like special last night actually so in
preparation for this so yay the hot
breath averse so exciting so chase asks
I've noticed you have expanded a few
jokes you did on Netflix have you
expanded the jokes since that show or
did you edit them down for the comedy
lineup example the I'm the man one bit
also 6 p.m. on a Tuesday is one of my
favorite jokes thank you did he did he
see me expand it when did he see the
other time that I did it where I
expanded on you think it was I think I
did the man won again on Colbert and I
had so I had just written that joke when
I did the Netflix so when I did the
Netflix I kind of wedged that in there
it wasn't planned it was like I was
vibing with the audience and we filmed
it two times so and I did difference
that's each time like the same price say
it's a 15-minute set they film with 20
minutes I edit it down I prided the same
10 minutes on each show and then I did a
different other ten minutes and the man
won stuff I like threw him in there and
I didn't watch my Netflix 15 for a while
after it came out because I was too like
nervous to watch it and then that man
won that was like the baby phase of it
where it was like just that thought and
then by the time I did it on Colbert I
had been doing it more and then I had
through doing it on stage had come up
with more endings and let me tell you
something that joke is way better now
than it was now I can't do anything with
it because I already did it
two times so now that Joe so that's a
bit that actually I wish that I had
saved but it's hard to know you're gonna
make also I think once I took the
pressure off of preparing it for TB
that's when I could really have fun with
that Joe so that joke is now I have much
more fun with it than when I was like
prepping it for something but it's like
okay now I've prepped it for something
you know maybe it's like in a
relationship after you stop getting
comfortable I mean it's not how can you
start getting comfortable and you show
all the sides of yourself and the person
still accepts you then it's like okay
now we can have more fun with what we're
doing yeah that's what it but the
difference is
I couldn't use that joke anymore per se
you know what was that what is the
preparation for like a late night set
are you transcribing are you rehearsing
like at home everywhere you go like how
tedious was that there's a lot of
there's a lot of transcribing and then
in my instance and what I've noticed
with other Booker's shoes like they come
around with you and they watch you like
I remember right before like pretty
quick before we went in quarantine like
that maybe like mmm that same month I
was seeing like I'll see the Letterman
Booker in New York walking or going
around with comics like running the set
and then he'll have them do a bunch of
sets at the different clubs and do notes
and then similar with Colbert and I'm
sure with the other ones like the Booker
will go around with you and then look at
notes and kind of edit with you or say
you can't say this you can say this
stuff like that I've never done letter
miss I don't know but I know he goes
around with the comic and they run a
bunch of sets and that was the same
thing with Colbert where you're like you
just like running it running running
running running
oh and chase said he saw the clip from
the Comedy Cellar
okay so when I did that Comedy Cellar
one I hadn't done that on a Tuesday joke
in such a long time and it was so fun to
do with that show so I did this show and
I remember just having a really good
time at that show and I ended up kind of
on a whim just I was gonna like edit one
new thing and put it up there but I
ended up on that set I hadn't done that
on a Tuesday joke like I think I stopped
doing it pretty soon after I did the
Netflix I hadn't done that on a Tuesday
joke in such a long time and it was so
fun to do it on that show because I was
just having such a good time that show
and I was like I felt like it would work
with the vibe of what I had seen before
on it so I like threw it in there and
that yeah that was really fun but I
stopped I don't really do that joke
anymore I don't think I've done it I
don't think I've done it in a long time
and then I haven't done it since then
but all bets are off me being crawling
on maybe I'll be the one I'll just be
the only joke all day oh no context
alright and let's get to let's well
thanks for watching
Oh chase I love that that's that's why
I've loved about growing this show in
this community
is like just just like the positivity
behind it and the support and how like
I've had several guests on here they
reach out to me and are like you know I
had a lot of people contact me after
your episode you're doing something
there so it's it's it's very inspiring
so totally in the process of comedy is
such a great thing to talk about I mean
obviously I'm biased but it's my
favorite thing to talk about probably I
mean that's what this whole show is like
Inside the Actors Studio for comics and
even like Alonzo was only gonna do 30
minutes and then at 30 minutes he's like
now let's keep going like he wasn't like
there's not really a show where we can
really there's a few out there where you
can really nerd out in an intellectual
way about comedy so and we're actually
having Jesse David Fox on here Wednesday
who is like he's like at the pinnacle of
nerding out on a comedy podcast he hosts
a good one
I was literally gonna mention that and
then I was like oh maybe it's rude to
mention another podcast oh no when you
were when you're saying that I was gonna
say with that yeah I listen to his I've
listened to a couple episodes and that
for writing is like great to listen
because you're man it's so interesting
to listen to hear about I was about just
like how people submit for things and
the process behind it
because we don't a lot of times - at
least for me if you see someone doing
something like Oh someone just gave them
that but then it's like you hear from
everyone they're like no I did this and
I did that and I got it's it's very
rarely did someone just get something of
course of course yeah and that's why we
love those details of like what happened
in the meeting like I've never been in
that room you know so it's it's yeah
there's a lot let's talk about sets is
another good one about comedy process
school of laughs is another good one
behind the bits is a newer one I was
just a guest on so oj said good one is
his favorite podcast no offense Joel
okay that's enough out of Chase Thank
You Jay oh okay so we'll let's get to
Earl's here and then we'll start to land
this plane he this is another process
Earl Anderson asks how important our
nonverbal cues for you wow that is such
a good question okay
that's such a good question because okay
also if I hit the thing it doesn't sound
definitely let me know it's all good I'm
just using my into my back yeah so
really important I'm gonna say too
important it's like so in the nonverbal
cues of the audience is like so
important to me so that's something with
Vegas that I had to be like no whatever
their their body language and cues are
you are you can modify that through the
presentation you're giving so it's
really really important to me because I
think those I think like nonverbal I'm
I'm assuming if he's talking about like
what the audience's body languages it's
really how I read the room before I go
up like that they all look at the body
language of people and suss that out
more than like any type of like what's
their age or what's the race class
gender any of that stuff okay you can
like read but the thing is in openness
like Jared freeze that can mean he has a
joke about when people cross their arms
in the front row it's like the
internationally [ __ ] you to comedians
just paraphrasing it but it's also like
how are they crossing their arms or
what's so I'll or if they are they like
looking around or they talking a lot or
they what's happening with talking a lot
obviously would be a verbal cue but are
they like shifting or looking or did
they like are they looking like they're
itching to look at their phone or are
they or they like so engaged and they
want to be laughing the worst the worst
nonverbal cue and this is like burn in
my head I was doing a show at it was
some put it was I was in DC and I loved
the comedy in DC and this couple had
come out to see me from a show of the
year before and I remember like wishing
I had had more new jokes like I think I
whatever amount of time and I'm I was
like wishing I had more new jokes and I
was doing a joke I knew I had done that
year before and I'll be like really hard
on myself even
it was like okay the same I did have
plenty of new jokes but I was still I
remember doing a joke I'd done the year
before and I looked at them and they
were like smiling like they wanted to
laugh do it in my I was interpreting
that they had seen it before and in my
mind I'm like okay from this body
language they're like disappointed that
I didn't write more now I have no idea
what's going on in their head I have no
clue but that nonverbal clued to me but
I took as warning the support wanting to
laugh and I'm not delivering it crush me
like I was like like I was so I remember
I can picture the woman's face looking
at her boyfriend and in my brain she's
looking at him like and so it's too
important to me I really and I read
books about like nonverbal communication
I can send you the titles I'm good I
don't remember my pants like like how to
use your like body language to be more
open cuz there I'd noticed a lot of
times me like putting my hand in the
pocket or like holding myself or stuff
that doesn't seem as open but I would
say those nonverbal cues really impact
my like timing on stuff yeah what do ya
what are some that you incorporate into
your performance as well like you said
the hand on the pocket and things like
that is that what he meant uh he didn't
clarify but I think that was valuable to
learn how you read the room but then now
how you actually perform for the room
it's great yeah it's all good okay so
nonverbal stuff to me
definitely facial expressions I like
incorporate a lot that I'm trying to be
more aware of because it can make a big
difference and I mean it doesn't make a
big difference
everything you're doing up there like
has quite an effect on everything else
you're doing because it's so stripped
down I mean just you in the microphone
and maybe there'll be like a piano or
something onstage but so everything that
you do is amplified because like like if
you were like if you hadn't eaten or if
there was like two chips I feel like you
like chew and enjoy those chips more
than if you had like a million pieces
chips then you shove them in your mouth
but then each chip you're like right
feeling the chip more
that example but like so the the
nonverbal stuff I think that the more
comfortable I am and the more like I use
my face that like really helps me
present the joke mm-hmm and like I
consider like pausing to be nonverbal
because you're not talking and I think
that that you know so much of comedy is
building tension and releasing it you
can release that tension non-verbally
through an action because you can say
something and then showing your face
that you disagree with what you're
saying or what you're saying is
incongruent with the expression on your
face humor can come from that because
it's incongruent so you need to but you
need to if you have a joke that relies
and that you have to make sure then do
the punchline as your face
oh and give an example now okay sorry to
put you on the spot there it was just
sounding I I've thought about it enough
that I should have some example but
there's definitely like faces that I'll
do especially if I'm like if I'm
pretending I'm like shocked or like
pretending to like think about something
were then I'll like say something and
then I'll kind of do like that uh-huh
you know and that's be trying to like go
with the reaction that I would think
they would be having and I mean
comedians I think of her I remember
watching Louie CK and seeing him
recreate moments that I had no idea were
premeditated like on stage watching him
like pause and then I don't know why I
said it like that Wow
and even that would be pre oh wow well I
would watch Andrew Schultz like I
remember watching him way back pause and
be like how's he [ __ ] pause like that
like he was like and like be like just
hold yeah I said to my girlfriend I was
like I was like I had said like you know
I think he's one of the best maybe the
best pause are in the game and when she
met him we were in a bus that just wraps
we were doing a charity basketball game
and I introduced them in she goes oh
Emma said you're like the
best poorer and comedy and I was like
hope that he that I meant that like as a
compliment I'm a compliment instead of
being like you know like I was like
digging the barrel for compliments like
you know he's good at causing but I
meant that and I think he took it like
that like building up the pausing is
nonverbal communication I think then I
think that it in comedy your nonverbal
cues and your facial expressions are
just as much as your words hmm
delivering and creating the thing and
your words you can fall back on if it's
a really tight crowd you usually have to
be more comfortable to make those facial
expressions and do those act outs but if
so the words you can always fall back on
but the facial expressions and
mannerisms and nonverbal stuff are just
as important as the other things but I
think they can be a little harder to
execute if you're not feeling really
comfortable I mean have you ever seen
someone do and act out when the crowds
not with them that's rough
I've been there yeah
right so you're acting it out and
they're like no and you still have to
keep pumping the stool or whatever it is
I backed out is mmm but no I don't I
don't I don't hump the stool I will dab
from time to time but with you and then
you're dabbing like if the dab see if it
that's five times right there dab and
you're just nothing you're like oh and
Earl said he was actually talking about
the audience so that's great he said I
was talking about the audience and
Christopher says it reminds him of
George Carlin's rage raised the bridge
advice where I guess come out George
Carlin talks about raising the eyebrows
when you talk so you don't look so angry
but you look more like this is crazy
right yeah all that makes a difference
there's a good interviews called on
comedy I'm sure you've heard those yeah
I listened to Seinfeld once
tons of times I love listening to him
talk about comedy because it's just so
the science of it
yeah yeah it's a good it's a good series
around trying to find Katt Williams talk
about his writing process cuz I'm just
so curious about that
excuse me but he I haven't I seen little
clips of him talking about writing on
stage but I would just love to get more
insight into what his writing process is
like maybe we'll get him on this show
who knows we'll see you believe is that
way oh that's right self-actualization
we learned it and we self actualize this
episode so thank you everyone for tuning
in Emma thank you so much for your
valuable time here we're gonna land this
plane mark says Emma you're fantastic
thank you so much for sharing it is
obvious you understand the mechanics so
that's a big compliment there so you
gotta understand the mechanics otherwise
how are you supposed to live in a car
you know what I mean if your work is
your word and the word realizing the
mechanics like you're like living in
that like a big portion of your life and
day then you get a you got to know the
mechanics though study them on goal I'll
still flip through like the comedy bible
or at night I'm always googling how to
write jokes how to write jokes I love
I've gone so deep in the internet for
those blogs because I just love read and
people say generally the same maximum 15
things maximum and I love reading it oh
that's so great this this far into a
comedy and you're still a student you
know that's cuz you're in love it's so
great you're a great example for comics
just to see what's possible that you're
from a small town in Maine with 2,000
people and now you like you've made it
like you're you're doing the comedian
life like you you tour you've been on
Netflix be on Comedy Central you've have
podcasts like you're a professional
successful comedian all from like a
small town that really shows that any of
us can really do it and we really
appreciate you like sharing the process
yeah
more than ever like I mean shoot me in
the head but I've heard rumors if you
can get some some tick-tock and I'm not
on tick-tock
I'm good on tick-tock yeah I'm really
going all-in on this Facebook group and
really helping to cultivate this
community because there's people all
around the world that are interacting in
here and sharing comedy tips and what
they've learned and getting - yeah yeah
we'll invite you to join that'd be great
because we're yeah we do q and A's like
weekly in here now and just we do have a
morning writing Club where we meet up at
10:00 a.m. and we write for 10 minutes
based on a random word so you're invited
that's so great yeah I'll invite you to
the group when we get off here and where
can cuz I guess you said you still have
two podcasts and where else can people
like support you and follow you and all
that jazz Instagram is my main thing
that I'm on all the time if you go to
owls and to answers and Willman on
Instagram and I'm posting a lot more in
YouTube I'm doing videos of the pipe ass
on YouTube for mms bunker and there's a
number on the YouTube header that you
can text me at it goes it's not my
actual number but it's doing app and it
goes right through my phone so I I get
it in real time
mmm and then on May 5th I'm gonna be in
this show I was a producer on it and
then I end up on after four episodes I'm
on the show it's called dirty works it's
a reality show it's on TBS May 5th so it
airs this tomorrow
Wow that's so cool yeah yeah dirty works
and she's really a character and she is
really interested in comedy - [ __ ] well
I can't actually just told me the one
thing to not talk about today but
there's really interested in comedy -
yeah and it's based in Maine you said
it's in me yeah it's in a town of 500
people in Maine oh you Google 30 works
the
oh that got her the show the it's this
viral video of her at a crafts fair
selling her moose poop someone just like
took it on their phone she did she
pitched the show and they're like no no
no someone took this video of her on her
phone at the craft fair Daniel Tosh had
her on and then that's how it came to be
Wow
so yeah we'll definitely keep an eye out
for that where can people see it again I
think if they're airing it right before
Impractical Jokers very nice that's so
exciting Congrats Emma and and people
definitely follow I would say Instagram
for sure and I'm just real quick do you
have a strategy behind your Instagram I
mean it seems like all your photos are
like very well like they're all
professional photos you have like
captions on your videos and all the
artwork you do is also like
professionally done it seems like it
seems like like when I look at comedians
I'm like okay what is the trend or what
are some like weaknesses of comedians so
I would see a lot of comedians don't
have great websites so it's like I
better have a good website so I stand
out from the more popular comedians and
like social media is another way to
stand out from the crowd and you seem to
almost curate your content with a
professional polish I'm guessing that's
intentional and strategic people I care
a lot about like people's time so if
someone's gonna take the time to go look
at my page I'm gonna try to put the best
foot forward there you know what I mean
mm-hmm like I definitely I definitely
think that that is really important also
now I mean it's like a given that you
should have these things but then again
also now if you can really cultivate one
of the things and make those work for
you then everything else can come around
to that but to make it work for you you
gotta be at least doing the best that
you can on there alright so step but
definitely go to Emma's page just to see
like executing social media on a
professional level and not just you
taking a selfie on the toilet so right
awesome well Emma this has been amazing
thank you so much for taking the time to
do this you
I'm gonna I'm gonna invite you to this
Facebook group and we'll all keep in
touch so thank you everyone for the
awesome questions and we will see you on
Wednesday with Jesse David Fox so have a
good day everyone
[Music]